how's it going everybody it's Warren
thanks for stopping by my channel today
and we have some news about one of our
favorite persons Stan the man Lee the
man that brought us so many of the
beloved characters that we know and love
the man that brought us the Marvel
Comics universe and the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as well and we have some news
about his last living cameo in the MCU
and I say living cameo because I fully
believe that they'll still give him
cameos but using CGI or pictures not too
long ago the president of Marvel Studios
Kevin Feige came out and confirmed that
Captain Marvel will not be Stanley's
last cameo and a lot of people went on
to say that spider-man far from home is
going to be Stan Lee's last cameo
although this was never confirmed
however in a recent Avengers end-game
interview the Russo brothers the
directors of the film came out and said
that they believe Avengers in game will
be Stan Lee's last cameo Giarrusso says
that he was not sure if Stan Lee was in
good enough health to do the spider-man
far from home cameo he actually says
spider-man homecoming but of course he
means the spider-man far from home cameo
and he also says some very touching
words about Stan Lee as well
[Music]
[Music]
well enough to do the homecoming caviar
huh but but it was incredible I mean I I
grew up on these comic books
Stanley was and I loved mine when I was
a kid and to be able to have the
opportunity to not only work on the
material that he created but to work
with him as a childhood dream come true
so it seems like Avengers in game could
be Stanley's last living cameo in the
MCU and not spider-man far from home so
be on the lookout for that when avengers
endgame hits theaters in less than a
month Stanley has done so much for I
think a lot of us I want to have my
channel without him and he's somebody
that will be truly missed let me know in
the comments down below what your
favorite Stan Lee cameo is and how
excited you are to see Avengers endgame
in less than a month and if you're new
to my channel be sure to subscribe so
you can stay up to date on everything
relating to Avengers endgame and Marvel
I also do monthly giveaways currently
giving away 5 imax tickets so you and
some friends can go see Avengers endgame
in IMAX if you'd like to interfere your
chance to win all you have to do is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and comment down below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero or
villain as always thank you all so much
for watching
Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you
[Music]